[Music]
that goes into if we're talking about
time travel
an episode that is actually i think
quite popular within the fandom
uh the episode 1969
the personally i hate
i don't i don't like it as an episode i
i've watched it two or three times i
watched it again today and always i
thought about this earlier and i was
going to say i didn't like it
yeah well about
i thought everyone's going to say they
like it so i might say i do but
it's it's a funny episode
but i don't like time travel episodes
generally speaking
i don't know how time was affected by a
supernova um i thought the and this was
written by brad wright and directed by
um charles corral um but i i just
thought it was it was a bit lazy just
because they wanted to
do the paradoxy type thing
um but i didn't really understand that
science so basically the idea being that
the as the wormhole came in it was hit
by a solar flare
that threw it around the sun a few times
superman-esque and that that caused them
to go back in time to 1969.
um
so it was just a bit of a lazy episode
the the science of it i agree with i
think like it doesn't seem
uh i'm not i'm not a physicist or
whatever
why are you on here then
i invited a physicist
dr matthew
[Laughter]
yeah i wasn't a fan of the episode
but i like it in the fact that it
brought that mechanic into the series
because it did open up a few really good
episodes later on down the line
yeah one of
it's going to lead into the new game the
timekeeper's going that's going to jump
through time a lot if it ever gets
released
um i don't know i you know the the the
one thing i think everybody overlooks in
about in this episode is
lieutenant hammond was a hottie
let's just get that right out there
he's an attractive fella
i'll fight you for him
i'll let you in i can't have what it
looks like let's have a look young
i watched the episode today and i have
to admit at no point did i go oh
lieutenant hammond
i'll make some of that steak sorry
[Music]
the guy who played young hammond
actually is
uh someone called major kearney in
season eight
i remember the major kerning uh
character i didn't realize that he's
he's hammond young hammond
no way that's completely off topic but
yeah
um i i do like elements of this episode
though i do like how they turned up at
cheyenne mountain
um and so i thought they were russian
spies which was kind of cool because it
was based in norway it was a weapons
testing facility at the
time um
i like how they did the whole paradoxing
with because it happened the general
hammond knew about it so he wrote a
letter to help them
um
the bit i really don't like is the
cassandra bit at the end
when they step through the gate ever so
slightly too late so they end up getting
thrown
further into the future than they mean
to
but because they'd survived it
sam was able to tell cassandra about it
so cassandra's there with a device it's
just a bloop and the stargate does that
thing that they do in later episodes
where it just goes it just goes zoom and
there's no you know what i mean and it
just opens it's like it's like
like how the knocks open it the knocks
open the asgard do it singing there's
more than i think yeah and but then they
then they walk through and then go home
the way they're supposed to so i thought
i thought the end was a bit it was a bit
like ah you know oh
it was like brad wright had written i'd
read a bit on time travel and gone
that'll be a good episode and written an
episode around it and throwing all these
little things in about paradoxes and
stuff um
but but i don't know it just didn't work
for me
and it definitely
going into the next episode it could
have definitely just not happened and
the episode would have been
absolutely fine
yeah thank you but we think that if we
if this episode was just never shot it
would really not have any uh
impact on any later episode
and story-wise yeah not really i think
it was just a lot of the jokes about
teal having to put a thing graham said
and stuff there was just a lot of them
and they wanted to do the whole 1960s
thing
you know please hit like if you are new
to the channel guys please like
subscribe hit the bell notification as
shelly has reminded me to do and if you
want to if you enjoy the content
become a fully fled sidetrack and hit
the join button because that gives me
money every month and the wife gets
happy and won't um make me stop doing it
um i've already suggested at the moment
that i should become a house husband
stay home and just do this full-time
and she should look after me financially
um and that was um
her retort to my plan was that what's it
going to be like living at your parents
house
and i'm just like
i was going to say hello how many likes
did you sleep on the sofa for that one
the thing was i think she thinks i'm
joking and they're going i'd have the
housework done and dinner would be ready
when you go home i'd be a brilliant
house husband i'd be amazing
man but anyway i'm not allowed
so the final episode of the series
me and matt are gonna i think we're
gonna argue on this a little bit
oh god i think it's a complete stinker
no no i i don't i'm not shut up man
i'm talking now
sorry
um
out of mind
is the episode with it's a two-parter
end of season um if you compare this to
the serpent's lair at the start the the
the two or three parts at the end of
series one into series two this whole
end the season it's an opening for
season three is it
is crap
um but o'neil wakes up he thinks he's in
the future it turns out he's not and he
thinks he's been a stasis doesn't he and
he thinks it turns out he's not it's a
goal plan to gather and tell and it
actually is a filler episode because
there's a lot of flashbacks and stuff
through it
as a filler episode it's quite a clever
one i think if this had been a
mid-season filler episode i wouldn't
have had a problem with it
um
but because it was an end of season
episode
i had a problem with it and also hathor
turns up at the end and i couldn't stand
that character i thought she was crap
oh i've got love gasps
it's like a batman 1960s batman bad guy
did you say lo i've got love gas she had
love gas
isn't that basically she belched and
people fell in love with her isn't that
basically how it works hey that's
totally wrong
okay never mind
i can't even
just never mind cut off my camera
i think
i'm sorry man i can't say your name what
is that peter that's an
amazing name um
as as a clip episode as a filler episode
it's stunning as a fine season finale
episode it's awful
and that's my point um
r.i.p
in love guess
see
i agree with you um
out of your mind being a terrible
episode
i've just seen what you typed
i'm just shocked
i'm the one that's shocked i was just
like
yeah
what
it's just a terrible episode
yeah so i i i i'm not a fan of out of
mind i do like this
for season three though i like the
second part
because it's not a clip show that's the
only reason i don't like out of mind
it's because it's just a clip show i
mean club shows let's just
they're they're kind of lazy you know
yeah
i think
24 episodes i don't mind a filler
episode if you do it cleverly and
stargate actually did do some clever
ones remember the president one yeah
well they have a new president and he's
reading the reports
yes and they have and these certainly
their little flashback bits that i
thought was a really clever episode
again it's a filler episode it's a
you know the actors really need a week
off episode
um but if you're doing 24 episodes
i'm okay that i don't mind
the difference with those ones is there
were they weren't a finale or an opener
yeah exactly that's the point yeah it's
a mid-season thing isn't it yeah
that's why i don't like it as a finale
it's not useful
i mean the cliffhanger is good
sorry
the cliffhanger is really good
in the fact that he gets that's a jack
gets turned into a gold
[Music]
you